und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und marietta slomka es
sind gewissermaßen mut bauern die heute
mit mehreren 1000 traktoren die
hauptstadt lahm legten
wut über neue gesetzesauflagen wut aber
auch darüber als verursacher von
umweltproblemen angeprangert zu werden
besonders regen sich die landwirte über
städte auf die klimaschutz zwar wichtig
finden aber trotzdem billiges fleisch
wollen
nun sind insekten sterben oder nitrat
belastetes grundwasser fakten an denen
auch die agrarwirtschaft nicht vorbei
kommt der protest der bauern zeigt aber
einmal mehr das ist bei umweltschutz
immer mehrere seiten gibt und damit
gesellschaftliche konflikte das gilt für
kohlekumpel genauso wie für dieselfahrer
oder eben für konventionell
wirtschaftende landwirte zumal die
agrarwirtschaft in besonderem maße von
politischen entscheidungen abhängt jetzt
schneider berichtet die wut tausender
bauern trifft berlin sie ist gerichtet
gegen die politik bundesumweltministerin
svenja schulze stellt sich als erster
den demonstranten verteidigt das agrar
paket gegen das sich die meiste wut
richtet es enthält unter anderem
strengere regeln für das düngen mit
gülle zu hohe nitratwerte im trinkwasser
können die folge sein
wir müssen uns um die qualität unseres
wasser kümmern
und wir müssen uns auch darum kümmern
dass es in zukunft noch insekten gibt
dafür gibt es klare regeln die brauchen
wir da lässt ein bauer aus der menge
heraus seinem frust freien lauf
er heißt die an bernd stolle aus
niedersachsen der mann links im bild mit
der graue kappe als er redet sehen wir
ihn leider nicht mehr hören ihn nur
nähmaschinen lesen die schüler hörten
wir sind nicht hier um zu lernen wie ich
arbeite in einem wasserschutzgebiet den
großen genesenen nähe von oldenburg ist
es sich ein bogen der zur unikat werden
und sie stellen die ministerin wird
ausgebuht kann sich kein gehör mehr
verschaffen oder in ruhe antworten und
verlässt nach wenigen minuten die bühne
[Musik]
die bauern hatten sich teils schon in
der nacht auf den weg gemacht und waren
mit tausenden traktoren in die
hauptstadt gekommen haben den verkehr
streckenweise lahmgelegt kartoffelbauer
christoph plass aus der nähe von
oranienburg hat den protest
mitorganisiert er ist konventioneller
landwirt mehr naturschutz heißt für ihn
mehr vorschriften weniger ertrag
wir leben alle von der natur und unsere
betriebe leben von den tour- und in der
regel auch im einklang mit der natur
und ja wir wollen ganz klar einfach
wieder auch mit mit an den tisch und
unsere argumente vorbringen und auch vor
entscheidungen gehört werden die
zuständige ministerin julia klöckner
spricht am nachmittag auch zu den bauern
verteidigt ihre politik gemeinsam
erreichen dass wir landwirtschaft und
gesellschaft wieder stärker und näher
zusammenbringen wenn wir das nicht
schaffen dann werden wir auch die
herausforderungen der zukunft überhaupt
nicht lösen können die landwirtschaft
gehört mit zu den am stärksten
subventionierten bereichen in
deutschland jeder deutsche zahlt
umgerechnet 114 euro dafür
naturschutzverbände werfen der
bauernlobby vor jahrelang reformen
blockiert zu haben
der deutsche bauernverband hatte eine
strategie die letzten jahre gefahren die
war
lasst uns in ruhe wir machen alles gut
wir brauchen keine änderung und übrigens
gebt uns weiterhin die 280 euro pro
hektar aus brüssel
die haben wir uns verdient und was nicht
blockiert werden konnte wurde verbessert
das führt uns jetzt in die situation
dass selbst kleinste änderung auf den
betrieben kaum noch luft haben
die landwirte haben berlin inzwischen
wieder verlassen nächste woche gibt es
einen agrargipfel bei der
bundeskanzlerin gibt es ja nicht die
bauernschaft sondern sehr
unterschiedliche betriebsformen und
interessen frank bethmann welche
entwicklungen und probleme gibt es da ja
nehmen wir die großbetriebe die sehen
natürlich ihre felle davonschwimmen sie
kämpfen an mehreren fronten nirgendwo in
europa sind lebensmittel so billig wie
in deutschland stichwort macht des
handels machte discounter im prinzip
nichts neues aber weiterhin aus sicht
der landwirte natürlich eine riesen
problem hinzu kommt neu die preise für
landwirtschaftliche nutzflächen pacht
oder kaufpreise sind in den letzten
jahren explodiert stichwort billiges
geld boden wird zum spekulationsobjekt
oder als bauland ausgewiesen und in den
letzten jahren musste der konventionelle
hof erwachsene um zu überleben
dort diese großen betriebs einhalten die
lassen sich ohne pestizide eben nur
schwer bis gar nicht bewirtschaften so
sieht es der bauer der heute eben auf
die barrikaden gegangen ist für ihn eben
einen stall voller probleme
dann war diese entwicklung zu mehr
effizienz oder mehr größe aber
politische auch lange zeit gewollt ja
richtig die agrarpolitik war auf größe
ausgelegt je größer der betrieb je mehr
subventionen nur zeigt sich das kann
eben auch eine sackgasse sein kritiker
sagen nicht ganz zu unrecht in der
agrarpolitik hätte längst umgesteuert
werden müssen nun ist man eben in der
problematik lebensmittel sollen
ungespritzt seien aber zugleich auch
billig und ohne macken das geht halt
nicht oder aber eben verbraucher sind
bereit mehr zu bezahlen stichwort bio
stichwort regionale produkte vom
landwirt um die ecke dort dieser weg
funktioniert eben auch nicht für alle
zudem sind die probleme der
landwirtschaft vielschichtiger stichwort
gülle stichwort treibhausgase deswegen
wird es eben wie angedeutet am kommenden
montag nun auch eben diesen
landwirtschafts dialog im kanzleramt
geben dazu eingeladen gleich 40
unterschiedliche landwirtschaftliche
gruppierung das zeigt eben auch den
einfachen durchschnitts landwirt den
gibt es schon gar nicht mehr
dankeschön nach frankfurt gekommen um
die kostenseite von klimaschutz ging es
heute auch im bundestag der
bundesfinanzminister stellte seinen
haushalt vor
und da war dann viel von einer
klimafreundlichen kehrtwende in der
finanz und wirtschaftspolitik die rede
und natürlich gab es darauf auch lebhaft
gegen den haushalt des ministers zu
durchleuchten in den fachausschüssen zu
verändern und dann später öffentlich zu
debattieren gehört schließlich zu den
vornehmsten aufgaben des parlaments
frankenwald hat sich die debatte heute
für uns angehört
eigentlich hat der finanzminister das
erste wort in der haushaltsdebatte
anders heute olaf scholz lässt der
opposition den aufschlag und die afg
zerpflückt das zahlenwerk gleich zu
beginn mit scharfen worten wirft dem
minister vor seine planung sei auf sand
gebaut und auf niedrige zinsen die
regierung profitiert von historisch
einmaligen sondereffekten
sie unterschlägt erneut gewaltige
risiken sie wirtschaftet auf kosten
spätere generationen und auf substanz
solche kritik lässt scholz an sich
abtropfen sein haushalt für 2020 hat ein
volumen von 362 milliarden euro und 5,5
milliarden mehr als in diesem jahr für
investitionen sind fast 43 milliarden
vorgesehen
der etat weise den weg in die zukunft
sagt der minister er gehört in eine
reihe von haushalten die wir den letzten
jahren auf den weg gebracht haben und er
ist der anfang der haushalte des
nächsten jahrzehnts die es schaffen dass
deutschland ein soziales land wird dass
es den technologischen wandel
beherrschen wird und dass es den
menschengemachten klimawandel mit
unseren möglichkeiten in deutschland
aufhält
das sieht die fdp die um ihren
verstorbenen fraktionskollegen jimmy
schulz trauert völlig anders die
konjunktur kühle ab nötig seien nun
mutige wirtschaftspolitische impulse
davon aber sei im haushalt nicht zu
erkennen
die frage kurzarbeit die fragen der
ängste um arbeitsplätze die frage des
wirtschaftswachstums die frage der
industrieproduktion die frage der
auftragseingänge hat nichts mehr im
haushalt nichts mehr im nächsten jahr zu
tun
man macht einfach weiter so die grünen
wollen mehr geld für den klimaschutz und
kritisieren dass scholz an der schwarzen
null fest hält also keine neuen schulden
macht dass sich die linke ganz genau so
die schwarze null ist ökonomischer
unsinn und verbaut die zukunft unserer
kinder und enkelkinder die rufe nach
mehr investitionen werden immer lauter
und zwar zu recht zukunft herr scholz
gibt
nicht zum nulltarif und kommen sie raus
aus dieser finanz politischen
intellektuellen verbohrtheit man könnte
auch sagen faulheit die menschen im land
werden es ihnen danken und in europa
ausbauen
ein spruch kommt von der unionsfraktion
wenn sie sagen wir müssen davon abrücken
weil die aufgabe ist heute so groß dass
wir jetzt schulden machen können die
spätere generationen zurückbezahlen
müssen dann ist es doch eine
grundsätzlich falsche annahme wenn man
glaubt ja die herausforderung heute sind
groß aber glaubt die herausforderung die
wir heute haben sind viel größer als die
die in zehn oder zwanzig und dreißig
jahren auf die menschen zukommt und das
können wir nicht wissen das geht um viel
geld gestritten aber wird vor allem um
den politischen kurs des landes
besonders leidenschaftlich wohl morgen
in der generaldebatte
denn von strukturwandel in der
automobilindustrie die rede ist klingt
das ja eher abstrakt war der nachricht
von audi heute wird's dann aber sehr
konkret geplant jetzt hat eben auch audi
einen weitreichenden personalabbau
angekündigt
9.500 stellen werden bei der vw-tochter
bis zum jahr 2025 abgebaut
zugleich plant audi aber auch bis zu
2000 neue arbeitsplätze in den bereichen
digitalisierung und elektromobilität auf
kündigungen will der autobauer
verzichten
frei werdende stellen werden nicht mehr
besetzt und vorruhestandsregelungen
angeboten
hintergrund sind auch schleppende
geschäfte aufgrund des diesel skandals
kinder sollen in deutschland rechtlich
deutlich besser gestellt werden
bundesjustizministerin lambrecht hat
einen entsprechenden gesetzentwurf für
eine grundgesetzänderung vorgelegt bei
allem staatlichen handeln soll künftig
das wohl des kindes angemessen
berücksichtigt werden
damit wird nach jahrelanger debatte ein
vorhaben aus dem koalitionsvertrag
umgesetzt
kritiker befürchten zu große eingriffe
des staates in den bereich der familie
die lage im osten der demokratischen
republik kongo ist verheerend wegen der
andauernden angriffe durch milizen und
ausschreitungen hat die
weltgesundheitsorganisation helfer
abgezogen die dort die ebola epidemie
bekämpft haben
um die gewalt in seinem heimatland zu
beenden hat der kongolesische
friedensnobelpreisträger und wege in
berlin einen transparenten handel mit
bodenschätzen gefordert der arme kongo
ist reich an rohstoffen um die
bewaffnete gruppen kämpfen
eines der schwersten erdbeben seit
jahrzehnten hat die westküste albaniens
erschüttert mindestens 20 menschen kamen
ums leben mehr als 600 wurden verletzt
das beben der stärke 6,4 es viele
albaner in den frühen morgenstunden aus
dem schlaf
häuser stürzten ein familien wurden von
trümmern begraben soldaten und
rettungskräfte suchen unter tonnen von
schutt weiter nach vermissten
mehrere eu-staaten und nachbarländer
entsandten hilfsteams zu den vielen
gewichtigen gründen aus denen in europa
die todesstrafe abgeschafft wurde gehört
dass es immer die möglichkeit eines
justizirrtums gibt dass der staat einen
unschuldigen tötet und damit selbst
furchtbares unrecht begeht
in den usa gibt es ja immer wieder solch
spektakuläre fälle bei todeskandidaten
oder lebenslang verurteilten
erschreckend häufig erscheinen
beweismittel dank neuer analysetechniken
in einem ganz anderen licht oder
geständnisse als ergebnis falscher
verhörmethoden ob der deutsche jens
söring zu unrecht 30 jahre in einem
amerikanischen gefängnis verbracht hat
lässt sich zwar bis heute nicht belegen
genauso wenig aber seine schuld und
darauf sollte es in einem rechtsstaat
doch ankommen es gibt keine
ausreichenden beweise und die polizei
befragung des damals 19 jährigen verlief
harsch träumt nun kommt er frei nach
mehr als drei jahrzehnten susan von
lojewski berichtet
sein bisheriges leben länger hinter
gittern als in freiheit zwischen diesen
bildern liegen mehr als 33 jahre 33
jahre in denen aus einem jungen
hochbegabten studenten der verurteilte
doppelmörder jens söring wurde noch vor
jahren hatte der heute 53-jährige eine
freilassung nicht für möglich gehalten
die todesstrafe schien ihm befreiung
in dieser situation ist der tod einer
lösung
als endlich frieden endlich ruhe ich
musste nicht mehr weiterkämpfen
das wäre schön nun wird zu ringen nur
noch um eines kämpfen müssen seine
rückkehr in einen normalen alltag
rückblick 1985 werden die eltern von
syriens damaliger freundin elizabeth
haysom brutal ermordet sie so sagt er
später habe ihm den mord gestanden um
sie vor der todesstrafe zu retten nimmt
er zunächst die schuld auf sich
der diplomatensohn glaubt auch er habe
immunität ein fataler irrtum vor gericht
belastet ihn seine freundin schwer
beide werden verurteilt hessen bekommt
90 jahre syring zweimal lebenslänglich
der anwalt andreas frieser vertritt
syring seit mehr als 30 jahren er ist
von dessen unschuld überzeugt ich bin im
lichte der gerade in den letzten jahren
aufgetauchten neueren erkenntnisse
stichwort dna stichwort falsches
geständnis überzeugt davon dass jens
führung nicht der täter war vierzehn mal
ist syring im gefängnis in virginia von
einer unabhängigen kommission die im
paroli bord befragt worden 14 mal war
die einschätzung die gleiche keine
freilassung nun soll es ganz schnell
gehen syrinx anwalt ist überzeugt dass
politische klima in den usa dreht sich
das umfeld hat sich geändert in virginia
auch die einstellung des gouverneurs hat
sich geändert es ist sicherlich nicht
unwesentlich dass er da gewissen
einfluss genommen hat das können wir
jedenfalls vermuten
und von daher war plötzlich alles anders
wie plötzlich jetzt alles geht ist auch
für die journalistin karin steinberger
eine überraschung mehrmals hat sie
syring im gefängnis interviewt morgen
fliegt sie nach virginia jetzt kommt zu
ring frei aber nicht weil man ihn für
unschuldig hält sondern wegen guter
führung
schöner wäre es für ihn gewesen wenn er
einfach aus gekommen wäre weil man ihn
für unschuldig hält und wenn man das
will ja immer anerkennt dass die fakten
alles dafür spricht dass er es nicht war
nach 33 jahren 6 monaten und 25 tagen
ist jens söring am ziel
freiheit eine freiheit die so sagte er
vor jahren nicht einfach sein wird weil
man sich immer weiter entfernt vom leben
was man hatte und das und dem leben das
man gehabt haben könnte jetzt wird
häftling 1 16 16 55 in deutschland
zurückerwartet
am nächsten wochenende hält die afg
ihrem bundesparteitag ab und wählt zwei
neue parteichef alexander gauland hat
zumindest angekündigt dass er sich aus
altersgründen nicht zur wiederwahl
stellen will
mal sehen ob es dabei bleibt york
wollten hingegen würde gerne
weitermachen
da fragt sich nur ob die partei das auf
milde um einen ernsthaften
richtungsstreit geht es bei den
personaldebatten weniger
der rechtsradikale teil der afd hat sich
längst durchgesetzt was gauland nach der
thüringen war ja auch ausdrücklich
bekannte als er den sogenannten höcke
flügel in der mitte der partei
verlautete damit ist die richtung
geklärt die frage ist eher welche
abstufungen von radikalität man ins
schaufenster stellt hinzu kommen
persönliche animositäten und machtkämpfe
david gerichtet
kein logo keine fahne keine
repräsentative parteizentrale nur ein
klingelschild gibt einen kleinen hinweis
dass hier der afg bundesvorstand seinen
tagungsraum hat doch wer hier künftig
über einem wettbüro die partei lenkt
darauf will derzeit niemand wetten
dieser parteitag wird sehr spannend wir
haben eigentlich fassen
personalkarussell wir haben viele
bewerber auf wenig plätze kein platz im
personalkarussell scheint derzeit sicher
im vorstand rechnet man mittlerweile
selbst mit gegenkandidaturen für
parteichef meinten etwa von ihr die
bundestagsabgeordnete nicole höhe ist
schwerpunkt familienpolitik beklagt die
kommunikation der parteiführung und eine
sprachpolizei
im netz präsentiert sie sich mit
wagner-musik und schreckt vor radikalen
tönen nicht zurück etwa wenn sie
kanzlerin merkel mit ball fiddler
vergleicht meiner meinung nach
verraten sie es nicht weiter hat die
machtergreifung längst stattgefunden
ja und der schnauzer trägt jetzt raute
es für den tod von millionen menschen
unter anderem sechs millionen menschen
ermordete juden verantwortlich diesen
vergleich wirklich angebracht
entschuldigen wir haben im moment eine
phase wo wir das den ausgang noch nicht
kennen und wir wissen noch nicht wo
diese geschichte die jetzt angestrebt
wird durch die die totalitäre tendenz
unserer ich sag mal herrschenden politik
wir wissen noch nicht wo es endet heute
wird von seinen gegnern seine
spendenaffäre angelastet und eine abkehr
vom rechtsaußen flügel den er doch lange
hofiert hatte und nun insbesondere in
seinem landesverband bekämpft ich stehe
definitiv für einen klaren kurs der sagt
extremistische positionen in der partei
nicht zu dulden dafür bin ich bekannt
das ist nicht neu das ist die richtung
die ich alleine für richtig halte auch
der zweite chefposten ist hart umkämpft
eigentlich hat alexander gauland timo
grub alle aus sachsen als wunsch
nachfolger ausgeguckt ein steuerbaren
ostdeutschen mit dem segen von rogers
völkischen rechtsaußen flügel
wir haben viele gute vertreter die das
sein könnten da hinten sitzt einer doku
aus sachsen
doch timo grub aller stößt auf
widerstand und konkurrenz gottfried
curio innenpolitischer sprecher der
fraktion hat sich mit radikalen reden im
bundestag eine art auf den starfaktor
erkämpft andere sagen erhitzt und schert
sich in seiner videobotschaft nicht um
bauland thronfolge pläne
indem wir den bundespolitik ändern und
ganz deutschland überzeugen und wir
können ganz deutschland hätten wir auch
im westen an stärke gewinnen
gauland will curio verhindern und
erweckte bis zuletzt selbst als
parteichef anzutreten
auch dana gut aus niedersachsen soll
wohl gegen kuba und curio antreten in
sozialen netzwerken tobt derweil eine
schlammschlacht um die vorstandsposten
kandidaten werden als blauer stalin
system ling lügen lord geschmäht die afb
sass untereinander
egal wer künftig hier führt er führt
wohl eine zerrissene partei die
renaissance des nationalismus ist ja ein
weltweites phänomen
das internationale konflikte gefährlich
verschärft und kooperative lösungen
gerade bei globalen problemen erschwert
auch für einen generalsekretär der
vereinten nationen sind das insofern
sehr bewegte zeiten antonio guterres ist
heute nach berlin gekommen zu einer
mehrtägigen digital konferenz
dabei geht es zwar vordergründig ums
internet aber natürlich auch ums große
ganze und die großen fragen unserer zeit
thomas reichert hat mit dem
un-generalsekretär ein ausführliches
gespräch geführt und die wichtigsten
passagen für uns zusammengefasst
der un-generalsekretär ist mit einer
warnung nach berlin gekommen an
deutschland und europa im exklusiv
interview mit dem zdf spricht herrisch
von einem neuen kalten krieg diesmal
zwischen den usa und china
es drohe eine aufteilung der welt und
gefährliche großmacht konflikte um macht
und einfluss
wir sprechen nicht von einem unmittelbar
bevorstehenden krieg aber wenn zwei
mächte eine solche wirtschaftliche
dominanz in der welt haben ist es sehr
wichtig dass ihre beziehungen mit viel
weisheit gehandhabt werden
und es ist auch wichtig dass andere
mächte aufstehen und genau da spielt
europa eine so wichtige rolle
europa soll spannungen zwischen china
und den usa ausgleichen so hofft er dass
die so gefährlich sind weil sie weltweit
wirtschaft handel und sicherheit
bedrohen
längst werden diese konflikte
ausgetragen auch in der virtuellen welt
im cyberspace wer die nase vorn hat bei
künstlicher intelligenz schnellen
mobilfunk wie 5 g/t diktiert die regeln
der hat die macht
dramatisch ist wenn bei der entwicklung
von künstlicher intelligenz europa
weiter viel weniger investiert als die
usa und china
das bedeutet nämlich dass europa in der
zukunft unausweichlich zurückfällt
es sind ganz undiplomatische warnungen
des uno generalsekretärs an deutschland
und europa seine hausaufgaben zu
erledigen und beim schnellen
mobilfunknetz 5g nicht allein auf der
welt zu setzen einen chinesischen
konzern unter der kontrolle der
kommunistischen partei
ich denke es wäre ein fehler nur einem
zu vertrauen ich denke wir sollten in
der lage sein ein system zu haben an dem
alle beteiligt sind und in dem es regeln
gibt die jeder akzeptiert
welche art von macht mit china nun auf
die weltbühne tritt das sieht man in
china chinas westlichste provinz gerade
erst haben neue enthüllungen gezeigt wie
dort die uigurische minderheit
systematisch unterdrückt und weggesperrt
wird die uno versucht seit monaten
zugang zu den lagern zu bekommen
ich hoffe dass der besuch der hohen
kommissarin für menschenrechte dort bald
stattfinden kann ist ich habe vehement
diesen besuch verteidigt und unsere
position hier wie in anderen situationen
ist ganz einfach es ist absolut
unabdingbar dass in solchen fällen die
rechte der minderheiten in vollem umfang
respektiert werden
eine zusage deshalb gut er es noch nicht
und china selbst erklärt die vorwürfe
schlicht für westliche propaganda chinas
neue macht es für gt risch auch
verursacht durch amerika schwäche den
rückzug der usa auf geheiß von präsident
trump von den konfliktfeldern der welt
in der physik gibt es lehrer aber in der
politik gibt es keine lehre sich jemand
egal ob im innen oder außen politik
zurückzieht mit dieser raum sofort von
anderen eingenommen
deshalb ist es offensichtlich dass wenn
eine großmacht sich zurückzieht eine
andere sofort nachrückt ziel ist der
klimagipfel man drin erhält die lage des
planeten für extrem gefährdet ist die
welt heute ein gefährlicherer ort als
noch vor zehn jahren
ich habe keinen zweifel daran dass die
welt heute weniger sicher ist oder die
machtverhältnisse unklar sind überall
sind neue konflikte entstanden keine
grossen kriege wie in der vergangenheit
aber konflikte die immer mehr
miteinander zusammenhängen und der
klimawandel ist zu einer existenziellen
bedrohung für unseren planeten geworden
es sind die warnungen eines mannes der
dennoch glaubt dass sich gemeinsam all
dies irgendwie lösen lässt
mit dem thema menschenrechte geht es
jetzt auch bei bundesweiter der
ukrainische filmemacher oleg sense of
hat den sacharow preis für
menschenrechte des europäischen
parlaments entgegengenommen
rund ein jahr
seine auszeichnung der 43 jährige saß
fünf jahre lang in einer strafkolonie in
russland in haft wegen angeblicher
terrorpläne
er kam erst im september bei einem
gefangenenaustausch frei sind soft rief
die abgeordneten in straßburg offen dazu
auf russland und präsident putin nicht
zu vertrauen
zugleich forderte er weitere
unterstützung für die ukraine
infolge des klimawandels ist die
durchschnittliche temperatur in
deutschland in den vergangenen fünf
jahren um 0,3 grad gestiegen
das geht aus dem zweiten
monitoringbericht der bundesregierung
hervor den umweltministerin schulze
vorlegte der klimawandel verändere das
wetter immer spürbarer sagte schulze
damit komme es vermehrt zu hitzewellen
starkregen und massiven ernteausfällen
nach dem juwelenraub aus dem grünen
gewölbe in dresden sucht die polizei
weiter nach den tätern eine heiße spur
fehlt
ermittler konnten inzwischen aber das
fluchtauto identifizieren
der wagen inklusive einbruchswerkzeug
wurde ausgebrannt in einer tiefgarage
entdeckt und eine gute nachricht von der
museumsleitung es wurden weniger
kunstgegenstände gestohlen als zunächst
angenommen wertvolle stücke wie brust
stern und degen sind noch da das grüne
gewölbe bleibt dennoch vorerst
geschlossen
zur champions league da ging es am abend
für bayer leverkusen bei lokomotive
moskau um alles im falle einer
niederlage wäre leverkusen komplett
ausgeschieden
es war also fast wie ein endspiel sagte
geschäftsführer rudi völler und dara
hassanzadeh berichtet
frostige temperaturen den moskau
heißblütige fans auf den rängen und ein
spiel mit endspielcharakter
all das überfordert die werkself aus
leverkusen sichtlich in den
anfangsminuten der frühe rückstand nur
der linienrichter verhindert ihn zurecht
nach elf minuten die erste ecke und ein
gastgeschenk von lokomotive moskau
doch selbst dieses krumme eigentor gibt
leverkusen keine sicherheit
das spiel macht weiterhin moskau ist
folgen angriffe im minutentakt ohne
treffer trainer porsch weiß dass sich
sein team nur mit glück in die zweite
halbzeit rettet doch dann lägen seine
spieler den hebel um die 54 minute sven
bender trifft volley zum 2 0-endstand
leverkusen kann weiter von europa
träumen
das zdf hat sich heute schon in mehreren
sendungen mit der gefahr beschäftigt die
von multiresistenten keime ausgeht
die reportage reihe 37° stellt gleich
zwei betroffene vor die seit jahren
gegen den unsichtbaren feind in ihrem
körper kämpfen und kein antibiotikum
kann ihnen helfen und um 0.30 meldet
sich daniel bröckerhoff mit heute plus
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter noch ist es
relativ mild aber allmählich kommt von
norden kühlere luft und die erreicht uns
dann spätestens zum wochenende und dann
werden wir das deutlich zu spüren
kriegen die temperaturen gehen deutlich
zurück
noch ist es aber mit und es wird nass
vor allem in den nächsten stunden und
morgen denn dieses tief über dem
vereinigten königreich wandert langsam
zur nordsee hier kommen die regenwolken
an und es wird dazu auch noch windiger
in der nacht schon kommt der regen im
westen aufsehen es hier ganz im westen
schon kompakte wolken ansonsten bildet
sich nebel
und ganz im osten und im süden da zeigen
sich noch die sterne
die temperaturen sinken am alpenrand auf
leicht frostige werte bis minus 1 grad
und 10 grad im westen deutschlands
morgen im tagesverlauf gibt es viele
wolken und es regnet immer wieder
tagesverlauf bildet sich teilweise auch
kräftiger wind aus vor allem aus südwest
ansonsten am alpenrand da kann auch mal
die sonne sich durchsetzen temperaturen
dazu erreichen höchstwerte von 6 grad im
südosten
13 im westen und 14 im südwesten die
nächsten tage gehen wechselhaft weiter
vor allem am donnerstag noch mit regen
und kräftigem wind aus süd west nach ost
länder zeigt sich mal die sonne bei 8
bis 13 grad
am freitag kommen schneeflocken vor
allem in den mittelgebirgen dazu bei
fünf bis zehn grad und samstag wird es
deutlich kühler aber sonnig bei 1 bis 8
grad
damit ein schöner abend